If you're thinking about Python you should have been able to figure out that at
least its an object, everything referencible is an object and to keep the design
consistent we don't want special things, we want everything to be an object. So
its some kind of object, what kind of object is it? Well is a value error. So
certainly the last one is correct, that it an instance of the value error type.
Value Error is a subtype of exception, so it's also an instance of an exception.
It's not an instance of the IO Error type and that's why the accept handler for
IO Error didn't handle the Value Error. Here's an example of the kind of
experiment you might do to understand what's going on here. So I've changed,
instead of having IO Error here, I've changed this to exception. So this means
any exception that's a sub-type of exception will be handled by this exception
handler. And what I'm going to do in the handler I'll print out the type of
exception then I have three assertions all about the type of e, the first checks
if its an instance of value error. We expect that to be true. The second checks
if its an instance of exception which we also expect that to be true. And the
third checks if its an instance of IOError, that we expect to be false. You may
of the guess what happens when an assertion fails. let's try running this code to
see, so let's see what happens when we try running this code and this is what we
get. We see that we got the exception and its type is type
exceptions.ValueError. Exceptions is a built-in module to python and we don't
need to import, we have the ValueError exception type, and we see that the
assertion on line 10 field, that means the first two succeeded. And, what
happened when it failed is we got a new kind of exception which is an
AssertionError. Congratulations if you guessed that what happens when an
assertion error fails, is you get an exception.